on va parler maintenant sécurité de roue
avec jean pierre hurel bonsoir tous mon
référent départemental sécurité routière
via un rallye moto touristique est
organisée jeudi 20 septembre à elancourt
c'est un rallye qui est ouvert à tous en
tout cas tous les titulaires du permis
moto bon c'est touristique et ça a quand
même une grande vocation pédagogique
exactement tout à fait c'est un rallye
qui est ouvert à tout le monde nous
espérons avoir une cinquantaine de
participants c'est ça c'est important
donc s'il va se passer en deux phases
quand même s'il ya une matin il ya une
partie 2-2 tout terrain de terrain
parcours de terrain dans le département
recherche de sa red touristique dont ils
vont rechercher certaines choses et
après l'après midi maniabilité avec des
sentiers curité routière bien sûr le
matin ils vont arriver à 7h30 et légale
des concurrents ça fait deux bonnes
heures en offre le petit déjeuner sert
je retiens remercie le restaurant de la
commanderie pour ça c'est une chose à
laquelle le partenariat très important
quand on organise une pédagogie sur le
dos ça c'est important donc ils partent
ce matin ils font un rallye ils ont des
90 km ils ont des questions et c'est une
question qui sont les questions sur le
code de la route tout à fait l'instant
de que de la route qui avant de partir
sur le parcours ils ont un petit stand
eux que de la route révision des
panneaux de voir leurs connaissances
l'enfer qui rappelle quand même que la
force de conduire tous les jours dont on
oublie certains pas nous on est ce
qu'elle mangeait que c'est ça justement
le danger du deux roues c'est comme en
voiture c'est pareil c'est l'habitude
quoi sony connaît notre trajet on
connaît par coeur on connaît les pièges
et poum il ya le mauvais piège mauvais
moment alors il faut dire que les
accidents de deux roues c'est vrai que
sur le département on a eu quelques
morts mais c'est pas toujours quelques
morts en 2011 la part la plus importante
des tués sur la route revenait justement
aux statuts et l'auto enfin tuer ben tu
es dans les deux catégories moins de 125
et plus de 125 c'est une vraie
problématique ah oui c'est pour ça qu'on
organise grâce à la direction
départementale en collaboration avec la
préfecture ce rallye moto tous les ans
les seuils de faire un rallye
pédagogique justement pour sensibiliser
les conducteurs du rouet les passagers
de deux roues si pascal c'est important
et vous le mentionnez mentionné sur
votre site internet c'est que c'est bien
de venir tout seul c'est aussi bien de
raccompagné parce que les accidents sont
aussi importants quand on a un passager
la conduite avec un passager n'est pas
la même c'est un comportement à avoir
quand ça c'est la sagi très important et
surtout il important de faire comprendre
aux conducteurs de deux roues le pal de
la circulation la circulation entre les
files de véhicules on le voit tous les
jours alors est ce qu'on a le droit
quand on est un deux roues de passer
entre les voitures non est ce qu'on a le
droit de passer à droite n'ont donc
c'est interdit par le code de la bien
sûr tout à fait vous êtes d'accord que
tous les jours on le voit tout le monde
va leur patientèle perrier parisien à
paris par ici c'est vraiment particulier
mais sur le département on à la brigade
moto du chenet qui qui est sur le
terrain justement au niveau répressif et
prévention qui interpelle beaucoup les
deux roues pour parler justement de ce
problème là la circulation entre les
files de véhicules et dépassements par
la droite qui est très dangereux soit
alors le matin donc rallye touristique
avec questions de culture générale sur
la côte de la route parce que il ya une
vocation vraiment pédagogique et
l'après-midi alors encore plus vocation
pédagogique c'est à la fois des ateliers
de maniabilité à la fois y aussi des
ateliers de recherche de panne c'est
assez divers alors on essaye justement
de leur faire comprendre on va les
pompiers aussi qui vont être sur place
la quinzaine de maurepas qui viennent de
mettre sur place afin de montrer des
gestes de secours pour le d'euros que
c'est important aussi de démontrer sa
nous avons des la fédération française
ces motocyclistes qui va être là pour
montrer l'équipement d'un motard quand
on s'aperçoit qu'il ya des gens qui font
des motos en short ou en tongs ma raison
on a vu cet été là donc il est important
de démontrer l'équipement ensuite la
maniabilité donc ils vont être testés
sur la maniabilité pour ça c'est
important et après les pannes d'une moto
et bien sûr ça peut arriver à tout
moment et votre avis quelle est la
première cause des tués sur la route en
moto est ce que c'est la vitesse est ce
que c'est le fait qu'on maîtrise mal son
ange puisque finalement quand on est aux
possesseurs de la date d'un permis de
conduire voiture on peut rouler en moto
aussi bien sûr qu'on peut vraiment tout
mais après c'est le comportement de
chacun il est vrai que le
malheureusement c'est toujours la tierce
personne
les gens qui sont voiture ne font pas
attention aux deux roues ils déboitent
sans mettre le clignotant le wilder ou
arrive à ce moment là une percussion qui
se fait il ya le moteur qui roule un peu
vite mais on est en moto c'est ça qu'il
faut sensibiliser ses sept vitesses qui
malheureusement est ce qu'on pensait
qu'il faut durcir la législation c'est à
dire par exemple un permis moto pour
tout
dire sinon que la loi est là déjà tout
tout est appliquée durcir plus non il ya
des radars qui sont implantés sur les
agglomérations je prends de versailles
où ils ont mis un radin justement suite
à un décès d'une jeune fille à me taire
la percuter bon ça voilà donc c'est
toujours bon de démontrer en ville la
vitesse d'un deux roues est très très
importante il faut oublier de parler
aussi pour le repas que l'oph le repas
tous les concurrents quand même et ces
jeunes et tous c'est là si c'était
class'croute voilà il ya un côté
convivial c'est le but c'est
convivialité exactement si cette équipe
voilà les actes restent conviviaux moi
je reviens quand même sur sur le côté
dispositif vous vous dites y'a pas
besoin d'un permis est large il n'y a
pas besoin de faire plus ben disons nous
avons nous nous sommes de loi qui sont
là pour pencher sur ce problème là grâce
aux 1 2 hommes de terrain où les
intervenants départementaux de la
sécurité routière qui font remonter les
informations qu'ils essayent de on
essaie de faire bouger un petit peu tout
ça mais je pense que la loi est bien
appliquée elle est positionnée ça va
aller là pour en faire comprendre en
tout cas nous nous sommes allés dans les
rues de 50 ans de compose des questions
tous les jours aux habitants on leur a
demandé s'il fallait un permis pour tous
les deux roues on regarde et on écoute
très bonne question
j'aurais tendance à dire oui pour ma par
mesure de sécurité pour le code de la
route
mais en même temps c'est un sujet qui
mène à réflexion et se serait pas un oui
définitif
maintenant un des roues pas besoin de
permis c'est à dire les 125 oui mais la
déroute centimètres cubes ça c'est un
ski ses brides et ça roule à 50 km heure
il ya la ccr déjà au collège compassé
voilà quoi c'est fini c'est pas utile
oui à partir du moment où on est sur
deux roues et que c'est motorisés je
pense que c'est important comme une
voiture un camion
ça peut être aussi dangereux
pense que pour les vélos ou y'a pas
besoin
maintenant pourquoi je pas j'estime que
chacun fectivement les parents
apprennent aux enfants et après ça
suffit non je pense pas que c'est
nécessaire d'autant que maintenant on a
donné du cassiot au tiers à l'école
du coup je pense que des guides les
enfants sont bien informés et des fois
sont même modérateur pour les parents
c'est intéressant ce que dit ce monsieur
en fait les intérêts ducation routière à
l'école royale mois on quitte un peu
monde des motos mais aussi le problème
du rousset aussi des maisons les futurs
coûts du taux se trouvait jeunes
conducteurs les jours aux explications
au départ tout à fait en école primaire
justement nous établissons la préfecture
établi le permis piéton et le permis
vélo pour aborder justement commun
bourdin puis un passage piéton et
comment faire du vélo en agglomération
et petit à petit ses enfants vont monter
en collège et on va leur expliquer la
sécurité routière qui est très
importante ce sont nos futurs
conducteurs en espérant d'avoir un
profil de bons conducteurs par la suite
arrive à 18 ans la conduite accompagnée
c'est une bonne chose par contre est ce
jeune homme dans le micro trottoir
parlait aussi d'un passage au collège un
passage de diplômes au collège alors
c'est la nécessaire en cinquième et à la
ccir 2 en troisième le 1 permet d'avoir
le bsr avec 5 heures de conduite dans
une auto-école et ensuite la nécessaire
2 permet de vous inscrire dans une
auto-école arrive à 18 ans pour percer
votre permis de conduire pourquoi c'est
bien en amont on prépare les futurs on
essaye de monter de plus en plus
justement dans les âges pour le
sensibiliser à la sécurité routière tout
derniers messages de prévention à faire
passer
soyez prudent venez vous inscrire à ce
rallye reste de la place encore je
laisse mes coordonnées téléphoniques je
croyais qu'il y a bon dos d'âne très
bien mais tout est expliqué c'est très
bien c'est ça qui est important et je
voulais remercier la casse qui pour la
cérémonie de clôture qui va nous
permettre de faire un classement
les meilleures connaissances et qui se
voit là exactement y'a pas notion de
vitesse et de temps c'est vraiment leur
abri on l'a pas dit c'est important je
veux juste passer un petit bonjour si ça
vous dérange pas vous êtes vus à orléans
gt1 précisé vous êtes je le sais qu'on
ait vu dans la france entière ben déjà
maison j'ai mes enfants et je voulais
faire un petit bisou à petite fille
voilà c'est tout ça voilà
cinq ans les manifs y aller on
t'embrasse voilà merci à jean pierre
merci beaucoup de mauvaises choses sur
ce plateau on va continuer dans l'esprit
mobilité avec auto moto rétro d'ailleurs
vous aviez un stand oui justement je
voulais parler de ça remercier les
collaborateurs qui ont travaillé pendant
toute la journée sur ce centre auto
rétro lui un instant de rétro police
nationale c'était sympathique c'était à
montigny le bretonneux on regarde aussi
ce reportage
cela fait 26 ans qu'existe le concours
d'élégance auto moto rétro sur montigny
le bretonneux et cette année on aurait
envie de crier vive la mariée à chaque
édition un nouveau thème imposé pour
tous les passionnés de voitures de
collection venus présenter leurs modèles
nous avons remporté le premier prix du
concours d'élégance c'est vrai que le
thème
céré monie mariage se prêter à ce que
les gens ont eu envie de décorer et ça
j'ai trouvé que c'était exceptionnel
quand même très inspiré patricia su
mettre en valeur sa coccinelle
volkswagen cabriolet karman de 1971
c'est le modèle 13 sentent de s un
moteur 16 cents un carburateur weber
double corps
c'est une 9 chevron la coccinelle de
patricia partager le podium avec une
jaguar une bentley une fiat 500 une
simca et trois motos l'événement
organisé par le club du minho temps des
vieux pistons s'est déroulé pour la
première fois au château de la couldre
sous un grand soleil très très belle
journée il y avait beaucoup de monde
beaucoup de voitures diversifié de
toutes marques confondues toutes marques
confondues il y avait à peu près pas
loin de 200 voitures le public lui aussi
est venu nombreux grands parents parents
ou enfants il n'y a pas d'âge pour aimer
les moteurs
ça fait peur c'est impressionnant aïe il
se permet en plus de réunir un petit peu
tous les gens et c'est très convivial
très agréable était super de voir tous
ces voitures en plus 6 et il était belle
moi j'ai bien aimé la voiture à la barre
elle était belle avec les groupes et
le club des vieux pistons donne rendez
vous à tous les amateurs de véhicules
anciens dimanche 23 septembre sur la
commune de mesnil saint denis où la
rencontre entre en modélisme et de
l'automobile